[MUSIC PLAYS]
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Hi everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Claudio and I'm one
of the engineers in the Google
Drive Developer relations
team.
We get a lot of requests from
you about what you want us to
talk about in Google Developers
Live, but there is
one topic that most of you ask
for, and that is how do I
write an Android app that
uses Google Drive.
This is a very common feature
request, and this is a very
important scenario for us.
So today I'm going to show you
how you can write your first
Android application
that uses Drive.
We also added this tutorial
to the documentation on
developers.google.com/drive
just today.
Probably two hours ago.
So you can watch this video, and
if you need some guidance,
you missed some commands, you
can always go back to our
documentation or you can
watch this video again.
It's going to be recorded and
you can watch it at any time.
So if we go to our
documentation, as I said, in
the home page we have the list
of five minute quick starts in
different languages.
The last one we added
is Android.
We recently added Objective C.
We're going to talk about it
in a future session of Google
Developers Live.
But today we're going to
talk about Android.
So if we click on this Android
link here we will be brought
to the Android specific page.
It looks like all the
other quickstarts.
So you might have seen this
quickstart already.
We covered most of them on
Google Developers Live.
The goal with these quickstarts
is to have an
application in a few minutes, an
application that integrates
with Drive.
As usual, being a quickstart,
we tend to cut some corners.
So this is not going to be
a perfect application.
We might not follow Android
best practices today.
But still, with by following
this you will have something
running and then you could
always go back to it and make
it better, make it a production
application.
If we look at our documentation
there are five
steps to have this application
running.
And the first one is very
specific to Android.
So the first step is generating
the signing
certificate fingerprint.
It's only required when writing
an Android app.
Android has a unique
authorization mechanism.
So it still uses Auth2, like we
do with all other languages
in all other platforms.
But it requires the developers
to register their package name
in signing certificates
in the API's console.
So this is what we need to
do as our first step.
If you're an Android
developer you've
probably seen this already.
Whenever you want to publish
an application on
play.google.com you have to
sign your certificate with
your product.
This is the same thing and this
is what we're going to do
and let me show how
this works.
So the first thing to do is to
generate the SHA1 fingerprint.
And you can do it by
using a command
line tool called keytool.
There is the command line
here in the Docs.
So if you're following
instructions, as I'm doing,
you can just select it, and
copy it, and execute it in
your shell.
So let me move to my shell.
I paste the command.
I'm using keytool to export
my certificate
from the debug keystore.
This is important.
Every time you write an
application in debug mode in
Eclipse it automatically
generates a debug
keystore for you.
So we're going to use that debug
keystore for our debug
application.
Whenever you want to move your
application from debug to
production, you have to generate
your own keys.
And this is well documented in
the Android documentation.
If you're using the debug
keystore, its default location
is inside a hidden folder in
your home directory and the
file is going to be called
debug.keystore.
When we ask keytool to export a
certificate, we are asked to
type the keystore password.
If you're using the debug
keystore password that is
automatically generated by
Eclipse, the default password
is Android.
So I'm going to type Android
and what I get is some
information about my key.
And what I need is the SHA1
fingerprint This line here.
We're going to use it
in the second step.
So we're done with
the first step.
So the first step is to recap
exporting your signing
certificate SHA1.
And this is done
using keytool.
Nothing special if you know
about Android development.
So let's go back to the docs.
So we're done with
the first one.
Of all those information what
you need is the SHA1
certificate, the SHA1
fingerprint.
So we're going to keep
him handy for later.
Second step is enabling
the drive API
in the API's console.
This is the same thing you
would do with any other
language in any other
platform.
So we go to the API's console
and we create a new project.
I'm going to click on
create project.
My session is expired.
I'm going to reload the page and
create a new project, and
then I have to enable
the APIs I need.
To Drive API application I need
to enable the drive API.
So I just click on Drive API,
click activate, and that's it.
The drive API is now enabled.
Now I need to generate
my credentials.
So to do that, I go to
the API axis tab and
click on create [? Auth ?]
2.0 client ID.
When I do, I have a step
by step wizard
that I have to follow.
In the first page I have to
specify my product name, my
application name.
Let's say it's going to
be Drive Quickstart.
You can also add a product
logo and a homepage
URL if you have it.
If you don't just move
on and click Next.
In the second page we have to
select installed application
as the application type.
You can select different
types of application.
One is a web application.
Otherwise a service account
application we also covered
those in another session to
Google Developers Live but
what we want is an installed
application, which is an
application that is installed
on the device.
So when I click on it I then
have to choose whether I want
an Android app, IUS app, or any
other kind of installed
application.
We're building an Android
app so this
is going to be Android.
And when we do we have to
specify the package name in
the signing certificate
fingerprint.
This pair has to be unique and
these uniquely identifies your
application, so that whenever
an API call comes from an
application, Google will check
if it matches this package
name and signing certificate.
So we have to be extra
careful here.
We cannot use a package name
and fingerprint pair we
already used.
So in our example the package
name is going to be
com.example.drivequicksearch.
If you use these values you can
basically copy and paste
the rest of the code from
the documentation.
If you change this, obviously,
you will have to change the
package name in your
application.
The easiest way to get started
with this quickstart, is to do
exactly as we do, which
is even using the
same package names.
And obviously my package name
will be the same as yours
because we will all use
com.example.drivequickstart
but my signing certificate
fingerprint, the SHA1 string
we generated, will be unique.
So the pair, package name,
and SHA1 will be unique.
So we need the SHA1 and we can
get it back from the terminal.
So let's go back here.
We need this SHA1 string
we just generated.
We copy it from the
terminal and we
paste it in the dialogue.
That's all it takes.
We can create client ID.
Now you can see in the API's
console that we have our
credentials.
So we have a client ID.
We have an application
type Android.
We have our package name
specified and our certificate
fingerprint.
Since this is the debug
certificate that Eclipse
already uses, when I will build
my application using
Eclipse it will be automatically
signed with this
same key, assuming that I'm
running it in debug mode.
So if we go back to the dock,
this is explained and we are
basically done with step two.
Step three is in Eclipse.
So we're going to create and
configure an Android project
that uses the Drive API.
So I have Eclipse open here.
I have no other projects,
so I'm going
to start from scratch.
I'm going to do file, new
project, and select Android
application project.
Here I have to specify
my application name.
In order for it to match what
we put in the API's console
the application name has
to be drivequickstart.
Remember if you change the
application name to be your
own, you have to match it
in the API's console.
So I'm going to type
drivequickstart.
And as you can see the package
name is automatically set to
com.example.drivequickstart,
which is what I have in the
API's console.
What I'm going to do next is to
set the latest version of
the target SDK.
So we now have devices with the
latest version of the SDK.
The Android SDK is 4.2.
So I'm going to have target SDK
API 17, Android 4.2 just
to get the latest.
And we're going to compile with
same version but with
Google APIs.
Everything else in this
dialogue, in this wizard, we
can leave it as it is.
So I'm going to click next.
The next part is about
some other
configuration in the project.
You don't need to change
anything here if you want to
follow the quickstart.
Of course, when you're writing
your application you will have
to change things here maybe.
You can set the icon.
We're going to use
the default one.
It doesn't matter.
Then when you have a production
app you can change
the icon and all the
other things.
And we're going to create
a blind activity.
Remember everything in Android
starts from an activity.
And this activity is going to be
called with a default name
which is main activity.
Its fine with me.
Remember, whenever you want to
write your own production
application you can change it.
You probably have to change
these values.
So I click finish and the
basic skeleton of my
application is created.
And this is how the application
would look like,
but we will see later.
We're not going to show
this page a lot.
So what this is the application
going to do?
This application is going to
fire up the camera, the device
camera, allow users to take
photos, and whenever a photo
is taken it will be
automatically uploaded to
Google Drive.
And that's very easy.
So let me show you
how to do it.
So the next thing we have to do
is to add the drive API to
the project.
We have a Java client library
that can be used.
And the easiest way to add all
the required .jars is to use
the Google plug-in
for Eclipse.
So this is one of the
prerequisites for this
quickstart.
If you install the Google
plug-in for Eclipse, then you
have a button in your toolbar.
And one of the commands
available here
is add Google APIs.
So if I click on that I see
the list of all APIs I can
add, just with a click.
So I'm going to look
for Drive API v2.
Remember, we have version
one and version two.
Version two is the newest with a
lot more features, but v1 is
also supported.
But I mean if you're building
any application you
should use Drive v2.
So I click on Drive v2, click
finish, and the plug-in is
going to download the latest
version of the Drive API
client library together with the
latest version of the Java
client library in all required
dependencies.
And add them to the project.
So it's very easy.
Not a lot of steps here.
It just adds everything
you need for the
application to build.
The only other .jar you need is
google-play-services.jar We
recently launched this
google-play-services.jar.
It is the new way for developers
to perform
authorization in Android
applications.
All I'm going to show
you here, uses this
google-play-services.jar and
what we did in the API's
console requires the
google-play-services.jar.
So we need to add the .jar.
You have to download the .jar
in your local computer under
the SDK manager and
then you can add
it to the Java project.
I already downloaded it.
Click on Drive quickstart.
I can do project, properties, go
to the library's tab and do
add external .jars.
I should browse for my
google-play-services.jar on my
local computer and add it.
Then I have to go to order and
export, to check the box next
to it and make sure the .jar is
exported when we build the
application.
So we added all the .jars, now
we need to add the code, the
code you're going to use and I'm
going to show it to you.
I'm going to show the app and
then I'm going to explain what
the app does step by step.
The code is all available
in a single file in the
documentation.
This is probably one of the
non-best practices we're
following, which is to put
everything in a single file.
Obviously, in a production
application you might want to
split the activities in the
files in separate files.
But here it is just easier
for you to copy and
paste all of this code.
It's not that long.
It's probably 100
lines of code.
And take all this code and
replace the one that we have
in Eclipse.
So I'm going to go to source,
my namespace, the
mainactivity.java.
I'll take all of this, delete
this and put my code.
If you used
com.example.drivequickstart as
your namespace in your
package name this is
going to build correctly.
Otherwise it would have to adopt
the code to match it.
The only other thing we have
to do is to add a couple of
permission to the Android
manifest.
So in the Android manifest you
specify what permissions your
application requests.
And this application requires
two permissions.
The get account permission,
which is for the application
to fire up the get account
intent and let the user choose
an account to use.
And the other permission
we need is internet.
Well, for the application to be
able to send HTTP requests.
So this is also covered
in the documentation.
We have this other box here.
So we need to take these two
lines, and there are multiple
ways to add permissions to your
Android app, but we need
to take these two lines
and put them in
androidmanifest.xml.
You just have to put it anywhere
inside of manifest.
That's it.
The application is
ready to run.
I already have Android virtual
machine running, which is
here, and it's a phone device,
an emulated phone device.
And so what I'm going to do is
click on debug to run the
application.
The application will be
installed on my device, and
we'll see what happens
in the device.
So the application is now
building and then being
installed on the phone.
And then it will be
automatically run.
So what this application does
is, first, it will ask the
user for an account to use.
This dialogue is fired
by an intent.
It's a standard Android intent,
and it lets the user
pick an account to use.
We want to publish photos on
someone's Google Drive, so we
need to select which Google
Drive account we want to use.
And this will list all the
accounts I have on my phone.
I only have one but you
can also add accounts.
It's a good practice to only
show this the first time the
application runs and then
remember this setting.
So the next time the same user
starts the application, you
don't have to ask it again.
We're not doing this in
the application in
order to keep it simple.
So I'm going to select
my account.
What happens next is that
the application
will fire up the camera.
If you've used the emulator
before you know that this is
how do the emulated
camera looks like.
We have this moving background
and we have
a box moving around.
This is a camera.
Of course, if you use your
physical device you will lose
your real camera.
But this is good enough for
us to see what's going on.
I'm going to take a photo,
beautiful, and confirm.
Now the application will try to
upload the file, the photo
we just took, to Drive.
The problem is the app was never
approved by the user, so
the application realizes
that we need
approval from the user.
And that's why this
dialogue is shown.
So this is a standard
dialogue.
Standard [? Auth2 ?]
It says, do you want
DriveQuickstart, which is the
name of the application I just
created, do you want it to be
able to view and manage the
files and documents I have on
Google Drive?
Yes, I do.
This confirmation will only be
asked once, so now we will
remember it.
And in the future every time you
use the same application
we will not ask for
[? DSAK. ?]
What's going on now is that the
photo was just uploaded.
I know the UI's not great.
What you should expect is that
maybe instead of a blank page
you show a progress dialogue,
things like that, but that's
an improvement we can do
to the application.
Now we can take photos, confirm,
and it will just send
them to Drive.
The only thing that happens it
will show a small toast, which
is a small message saying that
the photo was uploaded, and
then get back to the camera.
See, the photo was uploaded.
We can leave it running, but
if I go back to my Drive
account, this is the Drive
account for the same user, I
should be able to see the
photos I just took.
Or not.
They should be here.
Anyway they probably show up.
So let me explain this code and
let's see how it works.
Let's go back to the code.
This is all you all you need
to run this application.
As you know everything starts
in the own create method of
the activity.
So in own create the first
thing we do is to instant
shade our credential
using [? Auth2 ?]
And we're saying that we want to
use the Drive scopes, which
is the full scope that allows
the application to do
basically everything on
my Google Drive file.
After that we start
an activity.
So we fire intent, which is the
new choose account intent.
Which is as you remember the
first thing we the application
did was asking us for which
account we wanted to use.
So this intent will be uniquely
identified by this
constant, which is called
request account picker.
As you know, when we get back
something from an intent, we
have to handle it in a method
called onActivityResult.
So in onActivityResult we
check the request code.
First case what we want
is if we are in
request account picker.
So the user itself.
I just chose an account.
If we are in this case and the
result is OK, which means the
user has actually picked an
account and we have data, the
data we need is the account
name, which is the email
address of the user that
was chosen by the user.
With that we can set the account
name in the credential
and then we can use these
credentials to
get the Drive service.
So let me show you get drive
service and see what it is.
Get drive service is
here at the bottom.
We use the builder pattern to
build a drive service object,
which is the one that's
going to be used to
read and write files.
And what we have
to do with it?
We just have to pass some
parameters including
transport, JSON factory
and our credential.
And then we build it
and that's it.
So we have drive service with
our credential, and if we go
back to the activity,
what we do next is
starting the camera.
Let's see what start
camera intent does.
Start camera intent
does two things.
First, it generates a file
name for the photo
we're going to take.
And the file name is simply
image_timestamp.jpg, so each
photo is uniquely identified.
And once we decided what the
file name will be, we fire
intent, which is a camera intent
to capture an image.
And that's why after the user
has picked an account we go
directly to the camera.
This is still an intent, so the
result of the intent will
be handled by onActivityResult.
And onActivityResult has a
case for capture image.
When we capture an image and the
result is OK, we call save
file to drive, which is where
the Drive API calls her a
[? mate. ?]
So if we go to save file to
drive, there's a very
important thing here
to notice.
We are spawning a threat.
Why do we do it?
Because remember in Android
you cannot send network
requests on the main thread,
because if you do, DUI will
freeze and it will throw
an exception.
So whenever you want to do
network requests you have to
use a thread, or an an
[? async ?] task.
I decided to use a thread,
basically the same.
An [? async ?] task is basically
a wrapper around the
thread and some other
helper method.
But what this thread does is
reading the file that we saved
from the phone.
So when the camera takes a
photo, it saves it in a
specific location
that we define.
So this intent will read the
file from there and send it to
drive using this call,
service.files.insert.
So the service object, which is
the drive service object,
exposes the number of methods
in a number of resources.
One of them is files.
And on files we have different
methods including insert,
update, list, get, delete,
and so on.
So we call it, we execute this
insert request, and then we
get back to file, which
is the metadata we
got back from Drive.
When that happens or when
we get the file back--
we showed a toast, which is
the small message we saw,
which says photo uploaded in the
file title, and we saw the
camera again.
So that the user can go back
and take new photos.
There is an important
catch clause here.
So all of this was wrapped
in a try catch clause.
Why?
Because whenever we send the
drive service insert request
it might happen that the
application is not authorized
by the user.
Remember, the first time I took
a photo I had to grant
access to the app.
How is that handled?
So when the insert request is
sent, if the application is
not authorized, it will throw a
user recoverable [? Auth ?]
I/O exception that you
have to catch.
When you catch that exception,
you simply have to fire the
intent that is in the exception
and, we call it,
request authorization.
So this is what happened.
I sent a request.
The application wasn't
authorized.
So the first time I did it, I
went into the catch clause.
I started an activity asking
the user for permission.
The activity is handled like
all other activities in
onActivityResult.
And we have the two
cases as usual.
Good case the user said yes and
then we saved the file.
So we called save file to drive
again and that's it.
And this time it's
going to work.
If the user said, no,
then we go back to
choosing the account.
So maybe the user decided to use
a different account, and
doesn't want the app to be
authorized for that account.
So if that fails, you have to
send back the user to the
initial page and say,
OK, which account
do you want to use?
And this is what we're doing.
In our case I said, yes.
And I called save file
to drive again.
It did the same thing, the
request went through, and the
file was created.
The second time and all the
other times I use the
application, it will just
go there instead of
throwing the exception.
And that's basically it.
The only other method I have
here is show toast, which is
just a helper method to
show that message.
But you can use any kind of
notification you want.
You can even write to
logs and so on.
And that's basically it.
It took probably more than 10
minutes, but if you do not
have to talk through it,
and you just follow the
instructions, it's probably
very, very fast.
And as I said at the beginning
this tutorial is also
available on
developers.google.com/drive.
You will see a link
on the home page.
We think this is going to help
a lot of Android developers
that want to integrate
with Drive.
We had some reports that things
were not as smooth as
we thought.
We think they're now
much better.
But if you have any questions,
we'll be really glad to answer
your questions.
Please feel free to get in touch
with us on SecOverflow
on Google+.
And if you have Android
applications that use Drive,
please let us know.
We are really curious about
your integration.
And I think that's it.
I want to thank you
all for your time.
And see you next time on
Google Developers Live.
Bye bye.
[MUSIC PLAYS]